翻訳: Mai Iida
校正: Hiroko Kawano
KUMIKI PROJECTというプロジェクトのお話を
今日はさせていただきます
どういうことをやっているかというと
家具とか あと空間ですね 空間を
自分たちで作りたいと
思っている方をサポートする —
工具を貸したりとか作りかたを教える
というプロジェクトをやっています
どんなプロジェクトかというと
ちょっと簡単にご説明をします
これ よくある日本の賃貸の一室です
空き家ですね
これがつい最近 5月に
すごく大きく劇的に変わりました
こんな風に変わりました
何がすごいかというと
これ全部ですね 素人の方が作ったんです
こういう「自分で暮らしを手で作りたい」
と思っている人たちを 支援する
OK（笑）
支援すると
自分で「つくりたい」と思っている人たちを
サポートするということをやっています
ただですね 今日みなさんにお伝えしたい
僕のプレゼンテーションでお伝えしたいこと
たった１つなんですけれども
それはDIYじゃないんです
何をお伝えしたいかというと
「DIT」というコンセプトを
是非みなさんにお伝えしたいと思っています
Doing It Together ですね
こういう話をすると
例えばモノを作っていない方
ちなみにこの会場で家具を作っているとか
住まいをご自身で作られている方って
いらっしゃいますか
はい あ おひと方ですね —
ほとんどいないんですよね
それもみなさんしょうがないと思っています
午前中のプレゼンでもありましたけど
本当にみなさん忙しいですし
面倒くさい —
お金で買ったほうが早いと
大丈夫です 実は僕も
たった３年前まではみなさんと同じで
DIYとかDIT 自分で「つくる」ということを
１ミリもやろうと思ってなかった人間です
ちょっと昔のことを振り返ってお伝えします
大学を卒業して
最初は営業の仕事に就いてました
朝早く起きて 満員電車に乗って
会社に行って
ぎゅうぎゅうに押し込められて
夜まで 遅くまで働いて
時にはコンビニでご飯を買って
寝に帰って また明日朝行く
このサイクルですね
その時に感じてたことが１つあります
東京ってすごい人いるじゃないですか
こんなに人がいて
職場でもこんなに人に会うし
満員電車でも人がいるのに
なんかつながっている感覚がなくて
実はすごく孤独感を感じてました
だからFacebookとか
できちゃうと大変ですよね
「いいね」がつくと
嬉しくてしょうがないみたいな
そういう気持ちになっちゃう時期がありました
多分お分かりの方が
いらっしゃるかもしれないですね
そういう感覚が大きく変わって
モノを作らなかった僕が
作ってみようとか
そういう風になったきっかけが
実はあります
2011年3月11日 東日本大震災でした
当時ですね 震災のあと 復興の支援で
岩手県の陸前高田市に入って
最初にやっていたことが
地域の住民の方々と一緒に
まちづくりのお手伝いをしていました
そのときにやったのはですね
これ 杉のブロックなんですけど
間伐材で作ったブロックキットを
積み重ねていって
セルフビルドで —
自分たちの力で集会所を作りました
これが１棟目の集会所です
ありがとうございます
なんでこんなことをやったのかというと
当時ですね ある人が言ったんです
— 住民の方が
「子供達に瓦礫の町を
ふるさとだと思ってほしくないんだ」と
だからみんな夜の７時に 仕事終わりに
疲れてでも市役所に集まって
「こんな町できたらいいよね」とか
「こんな道路 作ろう」
「こんなお店できたらいいよね」って
すごい夢を語るんですね
でも皆さん想像してほしいんですけども
９時に会議が終わって
みなさん仮設住宅に戻るんですよ
たくさん夢を語って 現実を見て
夢を語って現実を見て が
２年以上続いて
心折れますよね
どんどん１人２人と
会議に来れなくなっていくと
そういう時に 流されてしまった
コミュニティセンターがあった場所に
もう一回集会所を自分たちで取り戻したら
来なくなった人も来てくれるかもしれない
何か１つでも変わらない景色とか
自分たちの暮らしがどうなるかも
全然２年経っても変わらなかったんですね
何か１つでもいいから
自分たちで形にできたら
ちょっとはまちづくりが進んでいる
と思えるかもしれない
その結晶がこの集会所でした
当時どういう風に作ったか映像もあるので
それをみなさんにご覧いただけたらと思います
ブロックを組んでいくんですね —
こうやって
表情に本当に注目してほしいんですけども
みんな本当に楽しそうにやっています
基礎はできているんですけど —
基礎の上
壁と床と天井 全部自分たちで
２日間で20坪 作りました
この会場の半分ぐらいですかね
仮設でやることがなくなったお父さんが
工具持って来るんですね
そのお父さんの背中を
子ども達が楽しそうに見ていて
お母さん達がランチを差し入れしてくれて
みんなで作っていくんです
これ 自動車の整備師さんが作って
最後餅まきで終了です
本当に楽しくて
やっていく中で ２日間でですね
中では踊り出しちゃう人も出てくるぐらい
（笑）
楽しかったです
ただ僕が一番心に残っていること —
何かというと
できた集会所じゃなくて
さっきみなさんに見ていただいた
人がつながっていくところ —
「つくる」っていうことを通じて
人がみんなつながっていくということが —
その光景がすごく—
今でも印象に残っているんですね
そういう時に地元の方[から]
ある言葉を教えていただきました
「結（ゆい）」という言葉 ご存知ですか？
地域には助け合いのコミュニティがあります
例えば田植えを
みんなで手伝ってやったりとか
ここに描いてある茅葺の屋根を
みんなで直すとか
お金をかけなくても 助け合いで協力して
暮らしを自分たちの手で「つくって」いく
というコミュニティがありました
それが陸前高田でも ああやって集会所を
みんなで作るという原動力になっています
この「結」という言葉を教えてもらった時に
かつて東京で孤独を感じていた僕は
こういうつながりがこの場所でも
できたらいいなと思ったんですね
首都圏でも 東京でも
こういう「結」みたいなものができたらいい
でもちょっとわがままなので
地域のしがらみはちょっと苦手ですと
なので現代のライフスタイルに
合ったようなつながり方ができたら
もっと心も豊かに
なるんじゃないかと思いました
そこで今やっていることが
ともに「つくる」ということを楽しみながら
人がつながっていくと
この瞬間 みんなでつながっていくという
人と人のつながり方 —
それを今DITという言葉で表現をしています
どんな可能性が生まれるのかっていうのを
みなさんに是非お伝えさせてください
もうすでに起きていることですね
例えば個人宅 —
親子で一緒に子ども部屋を作りました
お姉ちゃんと妹とお父さんとお母さんが
一緒に作っていた
手で作るということは
コストも下がるんですよ
例えばすごく高い家賃を払って
綺麗に完成された —
リノベーションされた住宅街に住まなくても
ちょっと抑えて でも気に入らない部分を
自分の手で「つくれる」としたら
暮らしがすごく豊かになると思いませんか？
シェアハウスでみんなで「つくる」ことで
人となりがすごくよく分かってくるとか
あるいは 日本って引越しが多いんですよね
新しいコミュニティに馴染む時に
「つくる」というのが
１つのきっかけになるかもしれない
さっきご紹介いただいた青木純さんのところで
コワーキングスペースも
みんなで作らさせてもらいました
将来このコワーキングを使いそうな人を
事前に集めて みんなで「つくる」んですね
そうやって事前に知るから
いろんなプロジェクトが今ここで生まれてます
今日法人の企業の方も
いらっしゃると思うんですけども
法人企業でも床をみんなで
社員さんで作ろうとか
働き方とか価値観が多様化している中で
ITのツールでコミュニケーションが
減っている中で
みんながつながるきっかけを
こうやって「つくって」きています
最後 学童保育 —
つい最近やったんですね
床を子ども達と保護者と先生と一緒に
作りました
もし地域の人も入って
一緒にこういうものを作ったとしたら
たとえば子どもの声がうるさくてとか
よく起こりやすいことなんですけど
少し地域の関係が豊かだったとしたら
そういうことが起こりにくくなるかもしれない
と思っています
今 日本社会って本当にいろんな課題を
抱えていると思います
最初に僕 孤独だったって
カミングアウトしましたけど
先進国で一番子どもが孤独を感じている国は
この日本です
20代から30代まで
死因のナンバーワンは自殺です
こんなにビルが建って豊かになった国で
何かがやっぱり足りないんだなと思います
「結」みたいなつながりを 現代の
ライフスタイルに合った形で「つくって」いけたら
こういう笑顔が
たとえば今日いらっしゃっている
家庭の中とか 会社とか
地域社会の中にどんどん広がっていったら
どんな未来がつくれるかっていうのを
すごく僕は楽しみにしています
たとえば「つくれる」人がたくさん増えた街
もし災害が起きた時に
とても心強いんじゃないかな
という風に思います
なので 今日はDITというコンセプトを
みなさんに是非お届けしたい
独りだと結構大変なんですね 「つくる」って
面倒臭いじゃないですか
集会所も独りでやれって言われたら
もう修行ですよ
（笑）
でも面白いんです
苦しいことも大変なことも
みんなでやると楽しくなったりとか
かけた手間が愛着に変わるんです
こういうブロックも 一緒に積み重ねる
相手がいて１つのものができると
すごく豊かなつながりができるんです
なのでそういうより良い未来を
みなさんと一緒にDITしていきたいなと思います
ありがとうございました
(拍手)